CLAUDIO CHERBINO:
Hello everyone.
MALE SPEAKER: Hi everybody.
CLAUDIO CHERBINO: Hi, today
this is really informal.
We are doing these Google
Developers Live, live from a
hackathon we're just running.
So nothing has been
prepared today.
And this is going to be--
well, hopefully it's
going to work.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And, yeah,
we're going to have people
around here.
So what's going on
[? Nicolas? ?]
MALE SPEAKER: So today we're
running a little hackathon.
So a bunch of people came
yesterday, and to basically
learn about Google Drive and
start hacking on Google Drive,
basically, building apps that
are going to use Google Drive.
And we have a bunch of prizes
to give to the best teams.
So today at the end of this
afternoon, like 3:00 PM,
basically, we will decide on
who's the best team, who has
built the best Google Drive
integration with their app.
And we'll have a bunch
of prizes--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Should we
tell them about the prizes?
And then people at home will
just be angry at us.
OK so we have three
Chromebook Pixels.
So you know the new
Chromebook, if
you heard about it.
It's probably a bit expensive,
but it's an amazing
Chromebook.
You should probably check it
out as soon as you can.
Yeah, it's just beautiful.
So three lucky people
here will get one.
And then we added on
a special prize.
I'm pretty sure many of you
tried to register for Google
I/O yesterday.
And I know some of
you succeeded.
But I also know that many of you
probably didn't succeed.
So we decided to add an extra
prize for people here today.
And sorry about you
guys at home.
So for the best app,
we will decide.
So it's going to be a special
prize for one of the apps.
And that special prize
is going to be
a Google I/O ticket.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, so
if you didn't win
the click-fest yesterday.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: It's
called registration.
MALE SPEAKER: The registration
process, sorry.
You might still have
a chance to win--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Well,
if you were here now
MALE SPEAKER: If you are here,
or if you're coming very soon.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So you
still have two hours.
You might want to come here
in the next two hours.
We're on the Google campus.
You should just go back in time
to yesterday, register,
fill the form, and write an app
that uses Google Drive.
And that's the easy part.
Writing an app for Google Drive
only takes 10 minutes?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And then
write the best app actually.
And then win.
Impress us.
Win.
And then you will get a ticket
to Google I/O. Easy, right?
So if you can stay here for a
couple of minutes and tell a
couple of jokes, I will go
around and grab some of the
participants and
have them here.
And then we'll talk about their
plans to dominate the
world and win [INAUDIBLE].
Just give me a second.
MALE SPEAKER: So he is going
around to grab a couple of
people who are going to
basically pitch their idea,
what they're building.
And I'm almost out of ideas,
so here we go.
Hello.
Could you tell us your name?
MALE SPEAKER: My name
is [INAUDIBLE].
Oh, there it is.
MALE SPEAKER: You can see
yourself here, on the camera.
And so you're today at the
Google Drive hackathon.
So what apps are you building?
What app are you building?
Something nice.
MALE SPEAKER: I've been
interested in
privacy for a long time.
I used to work at HP and
Snapfish and [INAUDIBLE]
for a long time.
And over the years I've become
interested in privacy issues.
So Google Drive is a
good place for such
applications I think.
So the thing I'm prototyping at
this hackathon is a way to
share files securely
on Google Drive.
Which puts the control of the
sharing in the hands of the
user rather than exclusively
relying on
Google Drive itself.
So for example you want to
share, say, it's tax time
coming up and you want to share
bank statements with
your accountant, you might not
want Google or connected apps
to index those apps necessarily
and then identify
[INAUDIBLE].
So what happens to an app
that's installed on
[INAUDIBLE], and they
use [INAUDIBLE].
So the keys are attached
with the device.
And so the files are always
connected with the other
person's [INAUDIBLE].
So it's secure, and it doesn't
rely on any third
party to do the work.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Are
you going to win?
MALE SPEAKER: Are you
going to win today?
MALE SPEAKER: It sounds
very tempting.
I think the I/O ticket is the
most tempting prize of all,
even more than the
Chromebook is.
MALE SPEAKER: Despite the
monetary value being less than
the Chromebook.
MALE SPEAKER: This is true.
But I think the desirability
is more
MALE SPEAKER: OK, OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Well I think I'd
be happy just to be here.
It's a great opportunity.
It's great to meet you.
MALE SPEAKER: We're
happy to have you.
About your team, are you
coding alone today?
MALE SPEAKER: I'm unfortunately
coding alone.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: There is just
one Google I/O ticket.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
that's a good match.
OK, thank you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you I think
Claudio has another
participant.
Hello.
Could you please tell us your
name then, and maybe tell us a
bit about yourself, and about
your project that you're
building here.
Anything you want to tell
to the world you
can do it as well.
JAY: Hello.
My name's Jay.
I'm building what amounts to
a standardized place for
everyone to start putting their
tickets with Google Drive.
And additionally, I'm going
to eventually try
to open source the--
the biggest issue I see nowadays
is I sign up for a
lot of events and go to a lot of
these sorts of things, and
I never have the authentication
to actually get
through to some of
these things.
And I know a good deal of
conference organizers that are
trying to put one on
later in the year.
And they cost $25,000 to
actually mail out all of these
conference attendee badges,
where you could just drop it
all into everyone's drive
in a unified place.
And not only do you have
a way for people to
print them out again.
But you can easily create an
authenticated, easy way of
knowing who you're
giving things to.
That and trying to suggest a
cool new way of offering
tickets to things.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Is your app
better than the previous one?
MALE SPEAKER: How is your
app better than
all the other people?
So today the demos are going
to start out at 1:00 PM.
All these great people are going
to come and show us what
they've built in just basically
24 hours, how
they're integrating
with Google Drive.
And there's a small jury made
of the Google Drive team.
We'll pick a winner and
distribute the prizes.
And about your team,
you're alone also?
JAY: I'm alone, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So you're going
for the Google I/O ticket,
basically or--
JAY: Hopefully.
It's a really cool conference.
And there's always advancements
on HTML 5.
And Google Glasses are
likely going to have
another update there.
And that's all you developers
out there putting Drive and
Glass together is probably
going to be huge
market in the future.
So hopefully we can all see
what's coming up there.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
CLAUDIO CHERBINO: Thank
you, and good luck.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you for coming.
CLAUDIO CHERBINO: And
we have another one.
And that's it and then
the [INAUDIBLE]
just keep coming up.
MALE SPEAKER: A third team.
DAN: Well, a team of one.
MALE SPEAKER: A team
of one again.
Sorry.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MALE SPEAKER: --get any bigger
team to come to this Google
Developer Live.
So could you tell
us your name?
Tell us about yourself,
and tell us about
your project as well.
DAN: I'm Dan [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a computer engineer here
in Silicon Valley.
I live here in Mountain View.
Mainly I came here just because
I wasn't really
familiar with the Google
Drive API.
So I just wanted to learn a
little bit more about it.
The app I have is a
pretty simple one.
I've got a friend who sells
real estate down in the
[INAUDIBLE]
Valley of California.
And I've been updating
her web page.
So I wanted to put a Google Map
up there that she could
highlight properties on.
And so I figured, well if I can
do that through Drive so
she can work with something
that's easy for her work with.
There's a form in
Google Drive.
And then I could pull out what
I need to populate the info
bubbles on the map.
Then that would be pretty cool,
and something that might
be doable in a short
period of time.
So that's what I've been
messing around with.
We'll see if I get
there or not.
MALE SPEAKER: You basically
pull lines inside a Google
spreadsheet and draw
that on a map.
DAN: And, yeah, do
the geolocation.
And then post the pin and the
info bubble with it to say
this the address, and how many
bedrooms and bathrooms it has,
and the list price and
all that stuff.
And you can see, I'm wearing
the Google I/O shirt.
So I was ready.
MALE SPEAKER: Over
confidence maybe?
DAN: It doesn't really matter.
But it's just good to be here
and find out some more about
the API with the people
who know.
Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks
for joining us.
CLAUDIO CHERBINO: We
asked for a team.
MALE SPEAKER: So since somehow
we only picked teams of one,
there is a real theme today.
Just to show you that
we also have teams.
So again could you just tell
us your name, a bit about
yourself, and your project.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
I'm [? Otto. ?]
I'm a [INAUDIBLE], which is
a platform for social
[? note-taking, ?]
leveraging Google Docs,
and lets students
collaborate on documents.
So we are here to build a site
application for online
students to take notes while
watching videos.
So our main idea was to embed
the video and [INAUDIBLE] and
install all the information
on Google Drive.
That's why we are here.
And last night we worked on the
synchronization between
video and notes.
So I met two of the guys who
work with me now, which is
really cool.
And one of the guys
has the same idea.
So it started on the
mobile application.
So I--
MALE SPEAKER: So
you teamed up.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So we will have a web
application and a mobile
application this afternoon.
MALE SPEAKER: That'd
be awesome.
CLAUDIO CHERBINO: What if you
win the Google I/O ticket?
Are you going to
fight over it?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
It'll be a really hard fight.
MALE SPEAKER: Would you
take the Pixel or
the Google I/O ticket?
MALE SPEAKER: I don't
know for the moment.
We have to talk about it.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Thanks for joining us.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks
for inviting us.
MALE SPEAKER: Back to Claudio.
CLAUDIO CHERBINO: And I'm
also part of a team.
It's called the Google Drive
developer relations team.
But we're not competing
unfortunately.
MALE SPEAKER: No, too bad.
CLAUDIO CHERBINO: Yeah, we're
not getting these Pixels.
MALE SPEAKER: Well no.
I would like a Pixel though.
CLAUDIO CHERBINO: Yeah, well
maybe we can get one.
OK, so people are coding here.
They still have a couple of
hours, and then they will have
to present what they
have built.
And then we'll have to decide.
So are we part of the jury?
MALE SPEAKER: I am part of
the jury definitely.
CLAUDIO CHERBINO: Oh, you are
more important than me.
OK.
I see.
So we'll have to decide.
And then we'll assign prizes.
And I guess tomorrow or next
week we'll write a blog post
to talk about this event, how it
went and who won, and what
was the app.
And maybe some of the apps will
be open source, and we
will share the links with you.
So I think we should
go back to coding.
And thanks to all of you
for joining live.
This was fun.
We've never done this before.
And it's like going live and no
studio, no infrastructure.
MALE SPEAKER: The little
studio is my laptop.
CLAUDIO CHERBINO: Just
don't say it.
Just say this is a professional
studio, and we
have perfect microphones.
And everything else is
working and lighting.
OK with that, thank you so
much for joining us.
I'm Claudio.
This is [? Nicolas. ?]
We are in the Drive developer
relations team.
See you next time.
MALE SPEAKER: See you.
Bye bye.